looking back 65 years and into the
future
tens of thousands of hungarians marched
through budapest in support of prime
minister viktor oban the date marks the
anniversary of the 1956 anti-soviet
uprising here but with the parliamentary
elections expected next april this was
also a chance for orban to rehearse his
lines
[Music]
brussels today speaks to us and treats
us along with the polls as if we were an
enemy we have a feeling of deja vu the
air of the soviet doctrine permeates
europe well it is time for them brussels
to understand that even the communists
could not defeat us
we are the sand in the machinery the
stick and the wheels
[Applause]
orban's right-wing fidesh party has won
three consecutive landslide victories in
the last 12 years
but with the next year's vote looking
tighter they've introduced measures such
as an income tax rebate for families
orbans also stepped up its strong
anti-immigration rhetoric
the 2022 election will be a decisive
election and we will have to join our
forces ahead of it
hungary is really being attacked by the
west
trying to stop orban is this man peter
marquis
whose supporters stage their own rally
he's the mayor of a small farming town
more importantly he leads a six-party
opposition alliance and their neck and
neck with pradesh in opposition poles in
absolute visa i am absolutely hopeful i
think this will be a very important
election the primaries have also shown
us that this will be a historic election
because there has never been such a
unity in hungary
the opposition leader is promising to
tackle corruption introduce a euro
currency and draft a new constitution
our basic goals for all of us left and
right is hungry to be a democracy to be
governed by the rule of law
in market economy and part of the
european union these four basic values
we all share the result of next year's
vote could have real implications for
the country's relationship with the
outside world
between now and then both sides will
continue arguing that they represent
true hungarian values
laura burden manly al jazeera